Okay. Hi.
Thank you.
First Steve, I'm calling regarding the balance on the account and will this be the best time to talk to you?
Sure.
Thank you so much.
Because upon checking here, there was a quarterly service that was rendered on May 27.
And the amount is $127.03.
And also the account was also being closed the same day as well.
May 27 also.
Yeah.
And would you like to settle the final invoice?
Okay.
As I told the supervisor, I was unaware that you guys were coming to provide any service.
Nobody knocked, nobody, you know, nobody, nobody rang, nobody did anything.
They just provided service.
My understanding was that the service was already canceled.
So the fact that you guys came out and you provided a service and we didn't like say anything.
I mean, I feel bad for you because you guys used chemicals, but I don't, I don't know your money.
Because I have already told you several times over the last six to eight months that I want to cancel.
And every time I've been told no problem.
And then you guys keep coming out.
So I will not be paying you for this last service.
And I already told the last guy that.
And he actually did not respond to me letting him know that he simply closed the account.
So by him doing that and not actually responding that that confirmed that eco shield agreed with me.
So my understanding is you guys also do not believe I owe you money.
I totally understand.
And my sincere apologies seriously for what you had experienced with the service, especially that you mentioned that you have been informed by the technician or you didn't even run the doorbell.
That he will be providing a service from that, from that day.
And also for that.
So I will just be putting on a patient and then under the account that you don't want to settle the final invoice for the service that was rendered on May 27.
But I would just like to ask us.
Steve, did you receive like an appointment notification for months?
I could text an email before the service.
No, prior to the.
No, we did not. Had we received one, we would have told you to come.
Okay, so upon checking here.
So Steve, there was a set appointment to my third required quarterly service that was sent on May 21.
I did not receive that.
To text.
How did you send it?
No.
To text and also to an email.
Three days prior.
Starting on May 21.
Sure.
There was an appointment notification that wasn't to text.
I am checking.
I am checking my email. I do not have a text message.
It was sent on May 21.
Okay, you can tell me all the dates you want, but I do not have.
And if I look at the emails, I have an email that says Memorial Day closure notice.
I have an email saying completed service.
And then I have an email that says receipt for that I did not authorize.
So you did not receive an email and received, didn't receive any access while correct.
No, I have zero notifications that you were coming to me.
Like I said, I would have told you not to.
I will be adding that on rotation under your countdown.
Since you mentioned that you don't want to pay the balance for this one.
You will still receive a call from us as long as the account has a balance.
But I will be putting on rotation with your concern for the service.
It's fine.
And it's not, I don't want to settle a balance.
It's one, I shouldn't owe you because I've already canceled the fact that you guys continue to try and get more out of me is unacceptable.
I don't don't like being jerked around by companies.
That's what I feel like eco shield has done with me for the last six to eight months to when I emailed the supervisor is and let him know that this is unacceptable.
And I won't be paying his response was simply that he closed the account.
So that sounds to me as though he accepts the fact that I'm not going to pay and that the invoice has been waived.
If that's not the case, then that was not conveyed very well.
And that just goes to show that eco shield does not have very good communication skills with their customers, especially the ones that aren't happy with them to begin with.
I understand. So all your concerns will be noted. And also I already also saw a notation here from the local office wall regarding the cancellation.
Thank you.
But as I mentioned, sir, I cannot guarantee that you will not receive a call from us since as long as the account is still have a ransom file.
Alright, so we're going to take more off your time. So Steve, do you have any other concern or question regarding this or building that I can help with?
Nope, not at this time.
Alright, thank you so much for checking my call and for doing business with the shield. Have a wonderful day.
You too.
Bye.
Thank you.